What is Jupiter gain?
Just a little bit more mass during its formation period and then ignited to
become a star.
How different,
what our solar system,
I've turned out what having another star in the middle of the solar system mess
with the orbits of the planets and would we see it from here?
This is what f and here's what would happen if Jupiter became a star.
Jupiter has more than twice the mass of all the planets in the solar system
combined.
It doesn't have a solid ground and is made up of the same elements as the sun
and yet it's not a star.
Jupiter doesn't have enough mass to initiate a fusion reaction in its core,
the necessary requirement to be accepted into the star club.
If only we could find 79 more Jupiters and crash them all into the one we have
now,
we'd be able to build a second star in the solar system.
What would that be like?
Ab Jupiter's crushed together would make a star out of the gas giant,
but that star would be nothing like the sun.
Jupiter would be massive enough to become a red dwarf,
a small cool hydrogen burning star,
and as every red dwarf out there,
it wouldn't be too bright.
0.3% of the sun's luminosity is the most light the Jupiter could hope to spit
out
because Jupiter is four times further away from us than the sun.
The earth wouldn't get much heat from it.
By and large,
Jupiter turning into a red dwarf wouldn't change anything for life on earth.
You'd still be able to see it from Earth.
Jupiter Star would appear red and a bit brighter than the moon at its full
phase.
What did at least have a gravitational impact on the solar system?
Not as much as you might think.
The former gas giant would slightly shift the orbits of the other planets,
but not enough to set them on a collision course with one another or to launch
them out of their orbits into outer space.
The only threat we'd face would be space rocks from the asteroid belt that
Jupiter might send towards the earth.
We'd need to learn how to detect and destroy them before they could reach our
planet.
Other than that,
not much would change for the solar system.
Things would get a lot more fun if Jupiter was replaced with a sunlike star.
If our gas giant became 1000 times more massive,
the solar system would go wild.
Asteroids would crashing the planets and planets would change their orbit.
Of course,
it's hard to predict what would happen to earth in this gravitational mess.
It could be anything from being pulled a little too close to Jupiter Star and
getting scorched to being left drifting alone in the void of space.
In any case,
it wouldn't be too pretty.
In the real world,
Jupiter is forever destined to be a planet,
and that's for the best.
Maybe someday soon we'll get a closer look and send a man spacecraft inside the
gas giant,
but that's a story for another.
What if.